yeah i feel like you've gotten to the
place
in your career where like sure you'll
take another cu again right because it's
one of the biggest songs of all time
right but at the same time you're with
khalifa like you're a [ __ ]
you know i think that there's probably
three other guys like in your category
as far as just like
my grandma knows who you are you know
what i mean like
um so like that's it gives you freedom
kind of
because you can just make what you want
and you can like you said like you're
you're trying to craft a project or a
new sound or
like you could be as patient as you want
yeah like my main thing is the message
so if the message isn't right or not
even that it's not right but if
if it's not telling the message of the
music yeah the message and the music
yeah absolutely
if it's not uh if it's
i don't want to just scratch the surface
or because i've already done that i'm in
the game i'm deep in the game
so i'm just being really really
conscious of the things that i say
and um i love what's being made in music
now
but there's no way that i could say that
and be completely fulfilled and
it takes time you know what i mean it
takes time to really put together of
a full meal for [ __ ] to really
digest
and and enjoy and um you know everything
that i
make i feel like is fire but it's like i
i'm
if you go fishing you can't catch every
fish like i want that big fish
so i'm really just shaving the fat and
figuring what is the message that you
want to like put out there in the news
there's a lot of different things um
with with young artists
um there's way too much violence with
with the younger artists man i just had
this
this kid julio from jacksonville here
and i had to like
i was like really trying to talk to him
like hey man like
i don't know if they got this beef going
on out there that's it's
so crazy so disrespectful like the
violence is crazy and it's yeah
there's so much of that and that's what
these blogs are feeding
our timelines too and it just feels like
yeah it almost seems like dudes are like
getting into it to start beefing with
each other like that's why you got into
rap to get like
so out of it yeah and if you think about
like you know wrestling piece of king
vaughn but like
the issue between him and quando rondo
like those guys aren't even from the
same city
right so like that was a wrap beef
rabbit
it'd be different if like king von got
into it with someone from chicago while
he was in atlanta but yo guys are dying
over rap beef
it's not productive for anybody and and
no one's
like where are the companies that are
behind these guys or the
the big homies you know what i'm saying
like well the labels are signing them
because that's what's like fueling it
and making it go further
because it's it's not really in their
hands it's like
it gets like just this type of the songs
that they play and the the words that
they say
how disrespectful they are to people's
families it's insane
it wouldn't be it wouldn't affect the
same
if it wasn't mainstream i agree if you
had to dig deep to find that stuff
then it wouldn't affect it the same but
there is
you have people who have nothing to do
with any of that
pushing singing it in the club or riding
around in their car listening
so it feels it puts so much more onto it
than actually would
be there if it was just beef did you see
the uh
vanessa carlton remix the thousand miles
remix where they're like on the golf
course
yo it's it's it's crazy yeah yeah you
should have a reference here
but yeah put it put it in now this kid
young and ace put out
you know a thousand miles with the white
girls the song from white chicks if i
could watch a thousand yeah they redid
that song
and literally just did a whole entire
song three minutes straight just talking
[ __ ] about
their ops dead friends by name that's
crazy it's insane
and it's it's like 25 [ __ ] million
views and it's like damn
yeah that's the type of [ __ ] what are we
doing
yeah i mean you should i like
yeah so you're so you kind of want to
come in and because i feel like there's
no balance right now especially with the
younger kids man like you know i think
there's like kids like cordee that are
amazing and yeah but as far as just like
it feels like there's a whole generation
that's just well i'm just speaking from
a perspective of not preaching to nobody
because i'm still living my life too of
course
but i'm dot i'm not no washed up [ __ ]
that you could just be like oh shut the
[ __ ] up we don't want to hear what you
got to say it's like no you have a
choice whether you want to listen to
what i'm saying
but i'm going to say it though